the next thing is when you've got sets
that sit within other sets okay so
here's an example
um yeah it is actually that's exactly
what it is um
illustrations here okay
now you remember we had the u for union
yeah like this and we had this
upside-down view for intersection so now
i've got a sideways one okay um
and
what is it what does it mean okay now
it's a relationship between two sets
okay what it means is
subset
b
okay
so this means that
everything that's in a
is also in b
everything that's in a
is also in b okay so hold on i had these
two sets before
why aren't there's nothing not being
done
oh no
hold on yeah yeah okay so hold on a
second uh oh what did i write i can't
remember now two three five two it's the
primes isn't it
five seven yep that's it
so
you can see here right
these two sets overlap
but
neither of these sets completely sit
within the other one okay so for
instance if i gave to you i'm just
thinking
uh i'll just i'll give you a boring
sound
c equals
let's just call it um
oh yeah we'll we'll call ck
okay
so we already defined a into section b
right it's just
two it's just two
so if i call that c
then c is
a subset of both of these everything
that's in c
is in a everything that's in c is in b
so i could write this
c which i'm calling
it's just two it's just two okay
um c is
a subset of a
c is also a subset of b
uh yeah i suppose you could i don't
think it's especially common i'm just
going to leave there's two statements
because it really is two seconds
okay
um so what's the definition
every element
in
points out you might get a really boring
case of this right for instance suppose
i introduced to you set d
and i said
let's call d this
okay
now this is an equal set with a right
remember i don't care about order okay
so
that's a bit weird but look you can see
that
d and a fit this definition right
every element in a is indeed right so a
is a subset of d
but d is also
a subset from a that's just a bit weird
right so what we tend to mean more
is this
without the line underneath it
let's go get this right a is b okay so
we call this guy we call this guy the
prop up
subset
okay which means that
everything is in a
is in b
but b's got something else right b's got
at least one element that isn't an a
okay so here's here's my diagrams now
okay um
i've got let's go with dna
here's d
and here's a inside it right and that's
two four and six they're subsets of each
other they're mutual subsets if you like
okay but a proper subset
there's going to be something else
you're talking about
no no i'm talking about i'm talking
about these two
which is
which is still this one i'm using
this symbol if you like the way i like
to think about it is think about your
language inequality which we're a little
more familiar with right so for instance
if i say a is less than b
right
it means that they can't be the same
number right like if they're both 5 then
that's not true but if i say is less
than or equal to b
they can be the same number so when you
see this it's like a is a subset or it's
equal to right they can't actually be
the same set whereas here
b has to be bigger there has to be
something in b that's not an n okay
um so it's this and
b has
a an element
not in a
okay if you want to draw the diagram for
a and c then it would be a with a big
circle
so let's just quickly draw
uh what did i say i need a new i need a
new set don't i
actually can say that c is not just a
subset of a c is a proper subset of a i
can't actually say that
be careful if you're like me you'll see
looks like something but anyway okay so
so that's where i've got this
is that okay can you see there are
elements in a that aren't insane
now we're talking a lot about elements
and what belongs to what okay so if you
take this subset um symbol right
and you introduce
a line in the middle like so what you
get
is the greek letter epsilon yeah
i introduced the news
so
if a number a
is an element of a big set a right
is an element of right so you've got an
object that belongs to a set
okay so for instance
look at the numbers we've got already i
can say 2 is an element of a
okay
2 is an element of a i'm not going to
draw a new diagram for that we've
already got enough diagrams
where you will see this most common
is when we say things like this
okay
um you remember i gave you some
quadratics before something like say
this i just think of an example x
okay here you go here's a quadratic
right
you can say either
no
real solution
i should write real
or alternatively you can say no solution
because
x belongs to is an element of
the real numbers and you'll see this in
textbooks this kind of language right
that's the shorthand for real numbers
okay x is an element of that set it's a
set of all of the real numbers that
exist it's an infinite set obviously
all right how are we going
it's a well it's two things number one
it's the um
it's the union and the intersection
symbol sideways and a line or
alternatively it's the greek letter
epsilon it's the it's the capital
epsilon
okay now there's
i think there's one other important one
here's our last important one today
before i set you off on a few
things um it's the idea of something
you're familiar with from probability
okay now not to be confused with what
this means in geometry in geometry this
means
two angles that add up to 90 degrees
okay which by the way how much trig have
you guys done
finished yeah nines how much trick have
you done
finished yes so you guys learned about
sine and
cosine right you guys know that the co
in cosine stands for complement right
yeah anyway
in
in set theory come on guys come on
refocus refocus
now like i said
different branch of mats
so it's got a different but related
meaning you've actually seen this like i
said in probability
if i say
either and there's a lot of different
ways to do this
you can see a with a um
with a wiggly line with a tilt over the
top
you might see a with a dash on it
or you might see a with a c for
compliment next to it
they all mean the same thing
as a personal preference
i think my personal preference is for
this one okay because later on when you
learn calculus this will be one of the
shorthands for differentiation
later on when you learn rating measure
that looks a whole lot like the unit for
radians so that's why i prefer this one
is it radius
you are
confusing what radians are with what pi
is the short answer is no
i can just say i can say two radians no
problem
it doesn't have to have five but anyway
we'll get on to that another time now
what does a compliment mean
ah now this is a bit tricky uh what this
means is all the elements
that are not in
a
right
that's right
but this then raises a question
for instance this is a up here right two
four and six
right
if we're not careful about this not a
we'll have like
it'll be an infinite set which will be
meaningless right it'll be all the
numbers except 2 4 and six so what they
do is
for each individual situation where's my
black where'd it go
they introduced this important set
just that we always just okay so this is
a u with an extra line on it it's what
we call the universal set now
its name is a bit of a misnomer his name
is a bit of a misnomer the universal set
changes for every situation you've got
you define a new universal set i'll give
an example
if we were if we had um a die rolling
dice okay the universal set would be
one two three four five six there are no
other meaningful values in that set
right
so if i said look a is two four and six
i could also say it's all the even
numbers on my die okay
now not a has a sensible meaning right
in this case not a would be
everything in here that isn't two four
and six
should be one three five
so in order to
define the complement of a you need to
know well what's the wider context okay
so here's the way that i would draw this
you've got these circles which each
represent sets around that you draw a
rectangle the universal set okay so i'm
going to call that rectangle
u
okay and then inside that right this is
what i call a okay so in this example
you've got 2 4 and six inside a and then
i have one three and five outside a so i
would color in
the outside of a that's the complement
of a
so i should put one three and five in
here shouldn't
you
okay
so here you go if i make this
the universal set
okay
therefore in this case not a the
complement of a would be
one
three and
five
okay make sense